je suis très heureux d'être parmi vous
c'est la malcombe bonjour et soufflé ou
non c'est une journée comme disait mon
prédécesseur assez exceptionnel mais en
somme toute normal par rapport à
d'autres critères il s'agit de vous
parler en quelques instants 15 moins de
15 minutes de ce que je crois de ce que
j'essaye de faire
à partir de ce que nous appelons
auxquels nous sommes attachés
c'est à dire l'algérianité ça a été dit
il n'ya pas d'avenir sans mémoire
je rappelle seulement pour commencer que
le premier roman écrit dans le monde a
été écrit par un algérien
apulée sa manière de se raconter ou
plutôt de raconter son rapport au monde
il parlait donc d'un certain nombre de
souvenirs du monde dans lequel ils
vivent et a pu les premiers romans
écrits dans l'est et dans l'histoire
d'un algérien
le deuxième qui a voulu parler de lui
après avoir après qu'a pu les parler du
monde
saint-augustin confession un autre et un
autre algérien
les premières grandes confection
confessions de l'histoire de l'humanité
le troisième 6 10 après avoir parlé du
monde puis avait parlé de soir appelé
saint augustin il faut parler du tout
c'est à dire de la société c'est le
premier qui a analysé étudier la société
de manière globale inventeur de la
sociologie et morale de notre g rien un
autre algérien au 19e siècle et tout ça
ce sont des références pour moi et pour
chacun dans
entre nous à été inventeur du droit
humanitaire international
comment se conduire dans les moments où
le jeu moi ou l'autre tu ou le nous ne
fonctionne pas bien
agression violence caire comment
vont-ils se conduire il a été inventeur
le premier inventeur du droit
humanitaire international l'émir
abdelkader reconnu par la croix rouge
internationale
toutes ces références on peut rien
trouvé d'autre de ces algériens qui ont
su dépasser le je le tue le nous au
moment où la difficulté du vivre
ensemble va le premier concept vivre
ensemble c'est le concept que je
travaille que je défends parce qu'il ya
beaucoup trop de discours de parole qui
nous empêche de vivre ensemble qui font
écran est d'abord les discours de notre
subjectivité notre arrogance de nos
prétentions à détenir la vérité
alors que personne n'a le monopole de la
vérité donc il nous faut aujourd'hui
comprendre en parler de huntington qui a
parlé du choc des civilisations publié
un livre chez odile jacob et alger il ya
une dizaine d'années qui parlait de
tolérance le louvre a de terence qui
répond à reading tonnes et en même temps
répondre à tous ces grains de sable
grain de sable parce que ce n'est pas un
mot par hasard le principal livre qui
parle de la fin de l'histoire de ces
idéologues qui parlent de choses
civilisation avec clinton seppuku yama
il faut créer un m'a dit justement ils
vont pas l'expression de grains de sable
il dit qu'aujourd'hui ça y est un seul
modèle va dominer le monde
le modèle occidental basé sur
l'autonomie de l'individu
sur le plan politique la raison comme
auteur et d'histoire et le capitalisme
qu'on production des richesses et des
idées il dit c'est le seul modèle
valable mais un grain de sable qui va
nous empêcher que cette machine
fonctionne dans tout les jumeaux ni du
monde et ce grain de sable
ces musulmans c'est l'arabe c'est
l'algérien
il peut faire bloquer la machine il le
dit constate dans son livre la fin et de
l'histoire
tout ça m'a interpellé pourquoi ce que
je suis comparer un grain de sable alors
que grâce à un civilisation arabo
berbère et lumineuse et méditerranéennes
et andalous sans nostalgie de l'âge d'or
a contribué à la modernité
alors on nous parle aujourd'hui de
postmodernité de hypermodernité de
transe modernité j'ai dit stop
est ce que j'ai le droit à une autre
modernité
les grains de sable sont anti modernité
et ceux qui imitent avec le mans le
modèle de ces dominant ne parle que de
modernité alors que nous avons le droit
et notre modernité à moi j'irai à mon
algérianité fier de ses racines ouverte
et sur le monde et lorsque je discute
avec un certain nombre de jeunes comme
vous certains me disent on veut nous
couper de nos racines
et puis d'autres nous disent non coupée
du monde et du progrès et de la
modernité
ça signifie croire que nous avons droit
ou deux nous avons droit aux racines et
et au progrès nous avons droit à notre
mémoire et alan et à l'amour et à la
modernité et c'est la médiane itélé
physicien et mathématicien salque la
médiane joue un rôle important dans
l'équilibré du monde ils s'aiment kamil
longue total c'est notre modèle est le
prophète même si nous prononcerons pas
toujours par bismil d'un parce que c'est
que nous savons qu'il s'agit pas
simplement de se faire cautionner et via
sylla et la raison mais c'est aussi en
même temps de ceux de se diriger une
norme qui m'oriente ni celle de la
fermeture parce que certains veulent
nous enfermer dans le repli peur du
changement et de la transformation et
d'autres veulent nous diluer dans
l'autre modèle qui n'est pas le mien
alors que j'ai besoin de raisons j'ai
besoin d'autonomie de l'individu utilisé
que le modèle de la modernité
occidentale
on dit que c'est l'individu autonome
auto centré maître et possesseur du
monde 10 des cartes et puis en même
temps je dis bien sûr je vais être
autonome même temps vivre ensemble c'est
important d'être commun comment vivre
ensemble
alors l'autre on met l'accent trop sur
la romandie communautarisme
lorsqu'on met l'accent trop sur
l'individu on dit individualisme nous
avons le droit de mettre l'accent sur
l'autonomie de l'individu la
responsabilité ni la le droit
d'interférer dans ma liberté de
conscience et dans mes choix et dans mes
goûts dans la créativité mais en même
temps il ya un être commun la liberté
commence la vie ni celle de l'autre il
n'y a pas de liberté sans loi et le
débat commence dialogue des
civilisations dialogue des cultures
dialogue et des civilisations et des
langues et des religions et c'est là où
je me suis situé depuis plus trente ans
on dit en tant qu'algérien j'ai le droit
à la parole et je la prends j'attends
pas comme la donne alors si un pape un
philosophe en l'occurrence des vidals
qu'il ose la modernité le pape ces deux
derniers disent des choses qui
m'interpellent je vais les voir et je
discute avec eux et je produis des
livres en disant voilà ce qu'il m'a dit
voilà ce que j'ai dit moi en tant que
algérien je cherche ma médias ni té la
ligne médiane le juste milieu
parce que les extrêmes de tous bords
nous fatigue ce qui va nous couper de
notre passé d'autres qui va nous couper
notre présent et notre avenir a expliqué
d'olive et hough et de vivre ensemble il
n'ya pas d'autre alternative que de
vivre ensemble un jour ibn arabi a
rencontré ibn rochd averroès r us lui
dit dans la télépathie il lui dit est-ce
qu'on peut arriver à la vérité à la
beauté au vrai au bout juste à partir de
la raison des capacités humaines qu at
il répondu
arabi à une loge une vraie rencontre
relater dans un livre ibn arabi il lui
dit oui il est possible d'arriver aux
vrais hobo est au juste
à partir de mes capacités humaines et
leur stream et l accent sur la raison
son visage s'est illuminé
quelques secondes après l'hymne à la vie
du oui et non et une heureuse sans
visage c'est un peu obscur su pourquoi
oublier non et puis parce qu'il ya un au
delà de la raison l au delà de la raison
et la raison est là pour m'aider
comprendre le monde à voir comment ils
fonctionnent où il ne fonctionne pas
notamment des sciences exactes d'essence
et technologique
et puis il ya la ayala et même temps et
à la sensibilité il yal'esprit il ya il
ya le il est le coeur il y à tous ceux
qui peuvent dépasser le simple calcul la
pensée calculante dont j'ai besoin pour
maîtriser le monde pour élever la
condition humaine
mais pour apprendre à vivre des
philosophes je ne sais pas apprendre à
vivre
j'ai besoin d'entendre l'autre pour les
ré ce n'est pas simplement toléré
l'autre parce que je peux pas faire
autrement mais parce que j'ai besoin du
regard de l'autre
j'ai des points d'arrêt blement j'ai
besoin de la critique de l'autre et sans
auto critique je suis pas crédible
si j'arrive parler au monde en tant
qu'algérien en tant que musulman peu
importe à partir de quel racines je
voudrais parler si je me présente
simplement qu'on victimes de ce monde je
serais pas crédible
si je me présente comme ayant le
monopole de la vérité je ne serais pas
crédible
j'ai besoin de dire j'ai une part et de
vérité est que ma religion par exemple
n'est pas venu simplement rappeler ce
qui est important rappelé elle n'est pas
venue annulée je n'allume pas notre jeu
n'est pas à aller à annuler l'autre
l'autre à sa part et deux aides et de
vérité et un jour rin sinon pour parler
encore ces penseurs qui sont aimés
référence à rencontrer un grand voyou
salaire un grand maître spirituel
ils se sont regardés qu'est ce qu'ils se
sont dit devant une assemblée
d'étudiants complet et précis n'a dit il
voit ce que je sais et l'autre qu'est ce
qu'il a répondu
il sait ce que je vois ils ne sont pas
exclues chacun à son rapport à la vérité
l'un par une pratique du rock du coeur
et l'autre par la recherche scientifique
l'un par la créativité de l'esprit et
l'autre par la réflexion et de la raison
il sait ce que je vois il voit ce que
j'ai c'est un peu comme ibn arabi et à
brûler du oui et non et c'est dans ces
espaces
nous avons besoin des uns et des autres
notre algérianité elle peut contribuer
aujourd'hui à rechercher ce qui manque
au monde ce qui manque aujourd'hui c'est
une civilisation
il n'y a plus de civilisation ni
d'asthénie
d'ouest ni d'orient ni d'occident nous
avons besoin des uns des autres et de
discuter de débattre et de dialoguer
pour retrouver un civilisation parce que
le progrès sera totale il sera pas s'il
est seulement matériel cela suffit pas
simplement moral cela ne suffit pas on a
besoin de vibrer avec le monde et
d'élever la condition humaine pendant
des sciences exactes et technologique
dans les sciences pédagogiques morale
éducatif sb tard l'air angie oui nous
avons besoin les uns des autres pour
retrouver ce qui fait défaut aujourd'hui
apprendre à vivre
cela m'a l'air
on